The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So you guys know
the quiz is cumulative, right?
Everything all the way
back from lecture one,
so I would look at all the
lectures and all the P sets,
and look at all the
stuff that we taught you,
so data structures,
algorithms, everything.
And at least be able to
know, for every one of them,
what's the name, what it does,
and wants the running time.
Proofs and how it does
it might be harder,
but these be able to
call it as a black box
and argue about
the running times.
So I have a dp problem, and
I have a non-dp problem.
Which problem would you
like me to start with?
OK.
Do you guys know the saying, if
a woodchucker would chuck wood,
how much wood would
a woodchucker chuck?
Today we're going to chuck wood.
So you have a piece of
wood that is l meters long,
and they have n markings.
So say the first
mark is at 3 meters,
the second mark is at 5
meters, so on, so forth.
And 3, and 4, all
the way up to mn.
So we want to cut this piece
of wood at all the markings.
The thing is the woodchucker
doesn't work for free.
If you give it a piece
of wood of length l,
and you ask it to cut
it at some marking,
you're going to get two pieces
of wood, length l1 and l2.
The price for this
is l1 times l2.
So we like woodchucker,
but woodchuckers would also
like our wallets.
So we want to cut
this up by paying
the minimum amount of money.
Rings a bell?
So I'll let you guys
think for a minute,
then I'll give you the running
time, then we'll start talking.
So we usually give you
running times on quizzes.
The running time is why you
should know all the problems
in their matching running times,
because the moment we give you
a running time you can
automatically eliminate all
the things that don't match,
and just focus on a few things.
So you're going to have to
cut it at all the markings,
eventually, but the order in
which you cut is important.
So if I cut here first, then
I'm going to pay three times l
minus 3, whereas if I
cut in the middle first,
I'm going to pay whatever this
is, and 3 times l minus m3.
So we're trying to
decide the order.
Does this look like
any familiar problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
using dp, right?
PROFESSOR: dp, that is good.
I did say that we're going
to start with a dp problem,
so this is dp.
It's a good start.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
Not exactly.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So, it is
not like any problems
on the recitations.
So far recitations did
prefixes and suffixes.
We're going to solve this
using a running time of n
cubed, which is like
the parenthesis problem.
It should be what you said, but
I don't know how to spell that,
so we're going to
go for this instead.
So running n
cubed-- the moment I
said this you guys
should know that this
is the n cubed problem that
we have in lecture notes.
So make sure to have
those on the cheat sheets,
and try to understand
them, right?
OK, so given that
I've said this,
you should know
the solution now.
To make sure
everyone is with me,
we're going to go through
the solution, whole.
So what is a subproblem?
AUDIENCE:Smaller piece of wood.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Like how to cut it up.
So this is how you
think of it informally.
When you write it up,
I want to see this.
I want to see dp of
something means something.
So how you fill
out your dp table.
It's really useful to
write this up on your exam
before, because one, this will
help you write the recursion
correctly, and two, if
the grader sees this
they might skim over the
recursion completely.
And then you might
have bugs there.
We might not see them.
Good for you.
So this says how you're
going to fill out the table.
Right? dp of something
equals something.
What's in a dp table?
Numbers.
It's never how to do something.
It's always the
numbers, so it's always
the maximum profit,
or the minimum cost,
or the shortest distance,
or the longest something.
So it's always a number.
So what we do here?
AUDIENCE: Start and dp, start
location to the end location is
PROFESSOR: OK, so we're going
to get the mean distance, right?
We usually do i j k and
whatever else it takes.
So start to end is?
AUDIENCE: The minimum
cost of cutting that up.
PROFESSOR: Minimum cost of
cutting up the wood board
from marking i, all
the way to marking j.
There's a tiny problem here,
that the initial-- there's
no problem for this big
piece of wood, right?
If I can only consider
the board from i to j,
so if I can only consider
the board from marking 1
to marking n, then
I get to this.
So this part and this
part get left out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
We add fake markings.
Then 0 is 0, and
mn plus 1 equals l.
Very good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
equally spaced?
PROFESSOR: No.
So these are numbers.
If they were evenly spaced,
I think there's an algorithm.
You might come up with a
math and say, you always
cut it up like this.
So while we solve this,
you guys have candy, right?
You should eat the candy and
be energetic and everything.
So min cost of
cutting up the board
from marking i to marking j.
I like this.
Have this on your
exam if possible,
because this will
make our life easier,
and it's going to
make your life easier
when you get to the
next step, which
is how do we compute dp of i j?
So suppose I'm looking at
the subboard from m1 to m4
so I'm looking at only this.
How do I compute the best way
to cut the board from m1 to m4?
What are my options?
AUDIENCE: The locations
you can cut it.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So in order to cut
this up, I can either
make a first cut at m2.
So say I make my first
cut here, and then I
recursively cut
this, and cut this.
Or the other alternative
is take the same guy-- m1,
m2, m3, m4-- cut it at m3,
and then recursively cut this,
and recursively cut this.
So I'm iterating over all the
markings inside the board.
Now suppose I'm
cutting it-- yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] cutting
both, or actually, never mind.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
when I recursed,
that takes care of it.
So suppose I'm looking
at m1 through m4,
and I'm cutting it at m2.
What's the total cost?
So what's the best way
to cut, given that then I
know I'm going to cut there?
AUDIENCE: The sum of the dp's.
PROFESSOR: OK, so it's the
best way to cut m1 through m2,
plus best way to
cut m2 through m4,
plus the price I'm paying
for this cut, right?
Not just the sum of the dp's.
One more term.
What's this term?
AUDIENCE: 4 minus 1?
Or the location of 4
minus the location of 1.
PROFESSOR: So,
not quite, almost.
So if I'm cutting a
board into two pieces,
the cost is the product of
the length of the two pieces.
m2 minus m1, times yes.
OK, why did I bother doing this?
Some people think better
with concrete numbers.
If that's the case, then
give yourself an example.
Write some numbers on
your sheet of paper,
then see what
letters match to what
numbers, and copy
it up using letters.
And there you go, you've
solved the problem.
So where are i and j here?
AUDIENCE: i would be 1.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this is i.
AUDIENCE: That's j.
PROFESSOR: Cool, so let's
try to write it up, now.
So in order to cut the board
from i to j, what am I doing?
So what am I computing?
Usually the first word in
your subproblem definition
is the function that
you're going to use.
So it's minimum, and I'm
going iterate over something.
AUDIENCE: dp of i to--
it has to be all of j.
dp of i, j, and
you're looking to--
PROFESSOR: So I'm
computing dp of i j.
AUDIENCE: I know, of
j minus [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: j minus i, then
k j minus [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There's a k, right?
I need a new variable for where
I'm going to cut up, right?
So fortunately, we have a lot
of letters in the alphabet,
i, j, k, so on and
so forth, l, m.
AUDIENCE: i plus k.
PROFESSOR: So let's say
that k is the place where
we cut, to make our life easy.
So I'm going to have dp of
AUDIENCE: Well i is
the starting point.
PROFESSOR: OK
AUDIENCE: And then, the
endpoint is i plus k, right?
PROFESSOR: So what's k here?
AUDIENCE: k is an actual number.
It's not the offset,
it's the actual number,
so it should be i to k.
It depends how you define k.
PROFESSOR: So I'm going to
make my life easy, and define k
as exactly the marking
at which I cut.
k is this 2 here.
And this is easier, trust me.
OK, plus?
AUDIENCE: k j?
PROFESSOR: OK, and?
AUDIENCE: Cost of m--
AUDIENCE: j minus i, m of
k minus m of i times m of j
minus m of k.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Yeah, other way
around-- doesn't matter.
So now where does k go?
We have to come up with
numbers for the loop, right?
AUDIENCE: Between i and j.
AUDIENCE: j minus i.
AUDIENCE: Just for k in i to j.
PROFESSOR: So if I have
the board from 1 to 4,
do I cut at 1?
I can, but that's kind of weird.
Because I'm recursing
on the same subproblem.
By the way, if you recurse
to the same subproblem,
what are you going to
get as your running time?
Infinite.
So let's not do that.
So we're going to go from?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So going
from i would be bad.
So i plus 1.
2?
AUDIENCE: j minus 1.
PROFESSOR: Very good.
AUDIENCE: Would it be m over
i plus 1, because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So k is which
marking I'm cutting at.
I never want to cut
inside a marking.
However, I don't even
know these are integers.
AUDIENCE: They wouldn't
be called [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So k is
which marking, i, j,
and k are which
marking I'm cutting at.
These are the only
discrete things I have.
This board is all filled
with real numbers.
So if I want to
cut somewhere here,
that's a real number--
I don't like that.
I want to have integers.
So my markings help
me get integers.
I only want to cut
at the marking,
so I always look at my problem
in terms of which marking I'm
cutting it.
So this always
iterates over markings.
So this looks very much like
the parentheses problem, right?
Same subproblems, roughly
the same recursion.
Turns out that these
problems, where
you're not considering
suffixes or prefixes,
but rather you're
considering substrings,
are reasonably hard to come by,
and reasonably hard to solve.
So if we give these
to you, chances
are they're going to be exactly
like the parentheses problem,
except for the cost function.
This isn't what we had in the
parentheses problem, right?
So you should be prepared
to solve problems
that look exactly like
the paren problem,
but might have a
different cost function.
And this is how we solve it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: When you say that
the complexity determines
which type of dp
example we use, does
that mean that a
problem can be solved
using any of dp examples?
It's just that the only thing
that changes is the complexity.
PROFESSOR: I don't
think you can map
every approach
onto every problem.
For example, if you tried
to map prefixes onto this,
you'd come up with
a solution that
doesn't look at all
the possible choices,
so your answer would
be sub-optimal.
So you'd come up with a fast,
but incorrect algorithm.
However, if you take the
problem of find the longest
increasing sub-sequence,
you can definitely
apply this technique to it.
It's more general than
suffixes or prefixes.
So it's going to work, but
it's going to be slower.
So in theory, what
you should do is,
you have all these techniques.
Given a problem, you
try all the techniques.
You see which ones apply,
and out of those, you
see which one gives you
the best running time.
In practice, if we give
you the running time,
you match it to the techniques
that match the running time.
You start backwards from
the stuff that you know.
OK.
Does this problem make sense?
Sweet.
Now let's do a hard problem.
Do people remember hashing?
You have one minute
to remember hashing
while I erase the board.
[LAUGHING]
So suppose we want
to implement the set.
The way we're going to implement
the set is, we have n elements.
We're going to put
them into the set,
so for i goes from
1 through n, we're
going to insert element
i, so first we're
going to insert all the
elements into the set.
And then after that, given a
random number, we want to see
is it in the set, or not.
So for some other number--
I used n before, so let's
use-- for some other number f,
we want to see is f in the set,
or is f not in the set?
What data structure would
you use normally for this?
A hash table, right?
You stick everything
into a hash table,
then you try to
find the elements.
If you find them,
then you say yes.
If not, then you say no.
Well, it turns out
that this would
take more memory
than what we have.
So instead, we're
going to do this.
We're going to have a
hash table of m bits.
So these are m bits.
And say we have a
hash function that
satisfies with uniform
hashing, so given any element,
the value is anywhere
from 0 to m minus 1,
and they're all independent.
So the way we're going
to insert an element
is-- this table is T-- we're
going to say that T of h of ai
equals 1.
So this is a table of bits.
For every element
we hash the element,
and we set the
corresponding bit to 1.
So we're going to have some 1s,
and some zeros in the table.
Say if this is ai, it
hashes somewhere here.
OK so the question
is, we inserted
n elements into a
table of size n.
Given a new element, f, where
f stands for false positive-- f
is not one of the
elements that we inserted.
I want to know what's the
probability that the set will
say that the element is
in the set, so basically,
the probability of
a false positive.
AUDIENCE: So what are we
doing about [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Nothing.
AUDIENCE: Is it chaining,
is it open addressing?
Does it even matter?
PROFESSOR: So we're not
inserting the elements
into the table.
This table only has bits.
The elements are lost
completely after we insert them.
So the tradeoff is
uses a lot less memory.
Instead of having to
store entire elements,
you just store bits.
On the downside you're going
to have false positives.
Because if I have a
different element,
say f, if it hashes
to the same location,
then the set is going to
say, yeah, it's in the set.
So you get false positives.
Would you get false negatives?
No, right?
Because you start out
with a table of 0's,
and you only set
the table to ones
for the numbers
that match to hashes
of elements that are in the set.
Did you have a question?
OK.
OK, do we understand
the problem,
before we attempt to solve it?
AUDIENCE: Is it probably 1/m?
PROFESSOR: You'd wish, but no.
AUDIENCE: It's less than n/m.
PROFESSOR: OK, I like that.
So what are you thinking?
AUDIENCE: If there are
no collisions previously,
then it would equal to n/m, but
there are collisions, probably
collisions.
PROFESSOR: OK, I'm going to
open up a window in your head
and tell everyone else the small
steps you took to get here.
So we have this new number f.
How are we going to check
if it's in the set or not?
We're going to compute
h of f, and we're
going to check if t
of h of f is 0 or 1.
f is different from
all the other elements.
So its hash value is independent
from all the other hash values
we had before.
We don't really care
about this anymore,
after we have the
independence assumption.
So h of f is just some
random position in the table.
So the question is, given some
random position in the table,
will that be a 0 or a 1?
How do you know?
If I knew how many 1's
I have in the table--
if I have k 1's in the table,
and automatically this means n
minus k 0's-- then what's the
probability that h of f will
point to a 1?
AUDIENCE: k/m.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the hash takes
m possible values.
k of them are 1's.
So the probability that the hash
is going to guess a 1 is k/m.
So if we knew how many 1's we
have, then this is the answer.
We know that we're going to
have at most n 1's-- that's what
you're thinking, right?
So k is definitely
smaller or equal to n,
so the answer definitely has to
be smaller or equal than n/m.
Now if you're in a
rush, you might say,
well, we inserted n
elements, so we're definitely
going to have n 1's here.
That is not true.
The hashes of all the
elements are independent.
So there is some probability
that two elements will
hash to the same value, and as
the number of elements grows,
that probability also grows.
OK, so now by
looking at this, we
got rid of this
part of the problem.
We don't care that
there's a new element.
it's a false positive.
All that we care
about is how many
1's do we have in the table
after inserting n values.
Well, what's that?
That's m times the probability
that a slot in the table is 1.
Right, the probability that the
slot in the table is 1 is k/m.
So if we know this probability,
and we multiply it by m,
then we get k.
People still with me?
AUDIENCE: And what does
that variable represent, h?
PROFESSOR: This is k.
Represents that my
handwriting sucks, basically.
AUDIENCE: I mean, why do we
do m times the probability.
That's the the expected
number of 1's in the table?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, this is E of k, I guess.
So then our final answer
is this thing divided by m.
So the answer is the
expected value of k,
or you can just think of it as
the average value of k, divided
by m.
So this is m times this
probability, divided by m.
So it is exactly
this probability.
So the thing that
we want to focus on
is, what's the probability
that a random slot in the table
is a 1?
AUDIENCE: It's equal to
1 minus the probability
that it was never fixed.
PROFESSOR: Exactly,
the first thing we do.
1 minus the probability
that a slot is 0.
This is easy, right,
like it looks easy.
But this makes a
huge difference,
because once we're here,
well, a slot is zero
if none of the
insertions made it a one.
And the insertions
are all independent.
So this is like,
you're flipping a coin.
What's the probability that
after you flip it n times,
you never get a head?
So this is 1 minus
AUDIENCE: 1 over m
to the something.
PROFESSOR: That--
So a slot is 0 means
that no number was
inserted in it.
We're inserting n numbers,
so it's the probability
that a single number
was not necessarily
in the slot, raised
to the power of n.
So we have n independent
experiments, right?
Every time you insert a
number into the hash function,
that's one experiment.
The hash function gives
you independent values
for all the elements.
So all the insertions are
independent of each other.
If, in a single insertion,
you've hit that slot,
then you've made
it a 1-- game over.
So the slot is only a zero
if none of the insertions
make it the 1.
So you take the probability
that the insertion doesn't
make it a one, and you
raise it to the power n,
because that has to
happen n times in order
for the whole thing
to be successful.
And the probability
that the number was not
inserted in a slot is
1 minus the probability
that it was inserted.
Right, we're doing this again.
1 minus probability
that a number hit.
Well what this probability?
Uniform hashing.
AUDIENCE: 1/m
PROFESSOR: 1/m.
So this whole thing is 1 minus 1
minus 1, over m to the power n.
1 minus m minus 1,
over m to the power n.
AUDIENCE: Can we go
through this again.
From 1 minus probability
of a slot is 0, to 1
minus probability of a number
was not inserted in a slot?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So first off, the
point of the problem.
It's our problem, right?
Don't panic, don't be angry.
You're not going to have
some this hard on the exam.
The point of this is, I want
to go through probabilities
a little bit, and I want
to go through hashing
and the math behind hashing.
Because remembering
that will be useful.
OK, so now you said you're
having trouble with this step?
OK, so let's see.
Let's do this here.
So we have this
table here, right?
And we have n elements-- e1,
e2, e3, all the way through en.
How do we put them in the table?
We hash each of them,
and each of them maps
to a random slot in the table.
If these are the slots,
then e1 might map here,
e2 might map here,
e3 might map here,
e4 might map here,
so on and so forth.
So I have arrows, right?
Every time I do a hash, that's
going to set something to a 1.
The numbers don't necessarily
map to different slots,
because each number, on its
own, maps to a random slot.
So these are all
going to be ones.
And everything
else becomes zero.
If no number maps
to a slot, it is 0.
OK, let's look at
one slot, any slot.
So let's say I'm looking
at this slot over here.
Can you guys see, by the way?
OK, so let's look
at this guy here.
What's the probability
that it's a 0?
So the probability
that the slot is
a 0 is the probability that
the first number didn't
map to it-- otherwise
it would be a 1-- e1
didn't hash to that slot.
e2 also couldn't match
to that slot, right?
So it's the probability that
e1 didn't hash to the slot,
and e2 didn't hash
into slot, and e3
didn't hash into the slot,
so on so forth, right?
All the way up until en
didn't hash to the slot.
This makes sense?
Now these are all
independent events,
because all the hashes
are independent,
by the uniform
hashing assumption.
So then I can turn
ands into products.
So I can say that this
equals to the probability
that e1 didn't hash into the
slot, times the probability
that e2 didn't hash into the
that e3 didn't hash into the
slot, so on and so forth,
all the way to the probability
that en didn't hash.
So since I'm dealing with
the same hash function,
turns out that all the
probabilities are the same.
So there, the probability
that some fixed number
didn't hash, to the power n.
So this is how I got
from here to here.
Probabilities and the
properties of hashes and hashing
assumptions.
So you guys should have
those on your cheat sheet,
and maybe if you have time,
review probabilities a bit.
AUDIENCE: What is
the probability
that any given one
doesn't hash, 1/m?
So if e1 doesn't
hash in that spot,
isn't that probability 1/m?
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
You're close, but not quite.
So you're saying that
the probability that e1
doesn't hash to
this slot is 1/m?
AUDIENCE: I guess
it's 1 minus 1/m.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
The probability that
it would hash here
is 1/m, because it has
to pick that one slot out
of n possible slots.
But if you're just
saying, all I want
is that it doesn't
hash here, well, it
means it can hash anywhere else.
So it has m minus 1 options.
It can go to any of
those m minus 1 places,
just not to that one place.
So m minus 1 over m.
AUDIENCE: It's interesting
it went the other direction.
Instead of saying, it's
1, it's 1 minus it.
Wouldn't it have been
just as easy to go
the other direction, or no?
PROFESSOR: No.
Not doing this makes
the problem hard,
so that's why we're doing it.
This kind of flipping is
easy to do conceptually,
but it might make a hard problem
into a really easy problem,
or at least into
a do-able problem.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
this the same thing?
I guess maybe not totally.
PROFESSOR: So it is exactly
the same in terms of the math,
but computing this without
turning it into this
is really hard.
AUDIENCE: Any given
slot is 1, isn't it
kind of like what we just
said, except if the probability
of any one mapping is 1/m,
mapping to a 1, right?
And then you take
1 over m raised
to the n, that's the
probability of it being a 1
at that one place, right?
PROFESSOR: No, not quite.
Yeah.
OK, so are we getting this?
Somewhat?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the probability
of a false positive,
you're saying that's what's
the probability that you
get the 1, if you actually
should [INAUDIBLE] the 0.
It's because multiple things
mapped to that one slot, right?
PROFESSOR: So the probability
of a false positive
is the probability that, given
a new element, when we hash it
we get the 1.
The hash of that new element
is independent of all
the other hashes.
AUDIENCE: Then why is
it simple in probability
that you get the 1?
PROFESSOR: So if I
have a new element,
I'm going to compute
its hash, and I'm
going to look in the table.
If I see a 1, I'm
going to say, oh.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's
a new element.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so it's something
that was not in the set.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Okay, cool.
OK, so let's see if we can
do a harder version of this.
So this probability isn't
great, but if we do one trick,
we can make this really nice.
And this puts together a trick
called bloom filters that
is used in all
sorts of situations.
So for Bloom filters, we
still have n elements,
and we still have
a table of m bits.
What changes this time is
instead of having one function,
we have k hash functions.
So when we take an
element and insert it,
we're taking element i.
The way to insert
it is we're going
to compute its hash value
using all the hash functions,
and set all the
corresponding bits to 1.
So insert ei becomes,
for j in 1 through k,
the table bit corresponding
to the hash function, j,
of the element is 1.
So each element
sets k bits to 1.
Now how do we check if an
element is in the table?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Since,
for every element,
we set all the corresponding
k bits to 1, now when
we have a new
element, we're going
to compute to the k positions,
and if any of them is a 0,
then we couldn't have possibly
put that in the table.
So all T of h j
of f have to be 1.
So for every element,
we hashed it k times,
and set the corresponding bits.
If we have a new element, and
by hashing we get here and here,
but we also get here,
and this guy was a zero,
we know we definitely
didn't put this in.
So now what's the probability
of a false positive?
AUDIENCE: My first intuition is
just raising that to a power.
AUDIENCE: The probability
that when you check--
PROFESSOR: Oh, I forgot to
say something, by the way.
The k hash functions-- I think
they satisfy simple uniform
hashing.
I'm not sure if that's
the right thing,
but they all have independent
values from each other.
So they're all independent.
So for any number you
give, any hash function
returns a value that's
independent of all
the other hash functions,
and they're all 0
through n minus 1.
AUDIENCE: Why is not that
just raised to something?
Because we know the
probability-- OK,
actually we need to
recalculate that.
AUDIENCE: Because it's the
probability that all of them
are 1, even though you
haven't hashed yet.
PROFESSOR: So the false
positive, the probability
of false positives
is the probability
that all the k slots that
correspond to f are 1's, right?
So, since the hash functions
are all independent,
this is the probability
that one slot
is the 1, raised to the power k.
Right, because they're
all independent slots.
So it's the probability
that one slot
is a 1, raised to the power k.
OK, so now what's
the probability
that one slot is a 1?
It looks a lot like
this problem, right?
Except there's a tweak.
How many times did we
put the 1 in the table?
So here, we put a 1 in the
table for every element.
So we have n sets, right?
So n times we're going to
set t of something to 1.
Right?
For every element,
we have one set.
We set one bit to 1.
It might have been said
before-- that's something else.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So here it's
raised to the m k?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, pretty much.
So here, for every element
we hash it through all the k
functions, and set the
corresponding bits to 1.
So one element generates
k set operations,
and we have n elements,
so we set n k bits to 1.
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: Can two hash functions
point to the same slot?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
But they're all
independent, and that's
the only thing that matters.
So every time we set the
bit, which bit was set
is independent of all
the other bits we set,
because all the hash
functions are independent,
and all the values are
independent of each other.
So this time, the table size is
still m, so that didn't change.
This time we set n bits to 1,
this time we set n k bits to 1.
So then the right thing
to do is copy this answer,
and replace n with n k.
And if you have to
write the proof,
you'd copy-paste the proof
and replace n with n k.
So this is 1 minus m minus
1, over m, times n k.
And of course you should
go through the whole thing
in your head and convince
yourselves that this is true.
AUDIENCE: Does that say one
of the elements is what?
k, something?
AUDIENCE: Sets.
PROFESSOR: Bit sets.
So one element sets k bits
in the table, not necessarily
different bits, just
independent bits.
So if you have n
elements altogether,
they set n times k bits.
This thing gets run n times
k times, whereas here,
the set operation gets
run n times in total.
That's the difference
in the two problems.
Right here you have one
function for each element,
here you have k hash functions.
This is hard, right?
Well, it's the hardest
hashing problem
that I could think
about and that
makes us go through
probabilities and through all
the hash stuff.
The problems on the exam will
be easier, so one, don't panic.
Two, review hashing,
review probabilities.
When I said, from the
theory, this is what you get,
if you didn't understand that
then please review the theory.
AUDIENCE: Why is
it raised to the k?
Because we did down there,
if we replace n with n k,
then we'd just get
everything except.
PROFESSOR: So this thing
in here is the answer
to the previous problem,
except you take an n
and you replace it with an n k.
So this is the probability
that one bit is set to 1.
But here, when you're
given an element,
you're going to hash it through
the k functions-- you take
this guy-- you're going to hash
it through the k functions,
and you're going to
check all the bits.
So you're going to check k bits.
So as long as any of the
k bits is a zero, not
a false positive.
So we need all the
k bits to be a 1.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: What if the hash
functions are dependent?
PROFESSOR: Then
become intractable.
AUDIENCE: And what if they are?
I think the in this problem,
the way they are being hashed,
that becomes
dependent, because I
think there were some problems
where, if something is being
hashed somewhere,
then the probability--
there could be
hash functions that
would put the other
thing in the next slot.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so you want
to reduce these problems
to independent hashing.
If you look at the
proofs, all the proofs
assume uniform hashing,
simple uniform,
whatever it takes to get the
math down to independence.
Because this is the
only thing that we
know how to solve
with probabilities.
If everything is
independent, then things
multiply and add up in the right
places, and everything is easy.
If things are
dependent, then proofs
become really, really hard.
So whenever you have
dependent things,
you want to find a way to reduce
that to independent things.
Is everyone tired,
or do you guys really
not like this problem?
By the way, really
cool trick-- so this
turns out to be a
lot better than that,
and I think the
optimal value of k
is around square roots of log n.
And that gives you some
filters with a really low
false positive rate.
AUDIENCE: What do
you mean by optimal?
PROFESSOR: Minimize
the false positives.
So given n and m, pick a case
so that this thing is minimized.
AUDIENCE: What was
the answer again?
Or actually, regardless
of that, what's
the percentage of
false positives?
PROFESSOR: It depends on
what your n and m are, right?
The more bits you can afford
AUDIENCE: But if
maximize your k,
you said you came up with
some k that's maximized
PROFESSOR: I think k is
AUDIENCE: Square root of log n.
AUDIENCE: So then
if you use that.
PROFESSOR: Let's
not do the math.
[LAUGHTER]
It's really, really good.
So these are used for all sorts
of practical problems, all
the way from branch predictors
in processors, to databases.
AUDIENCE: So is
it better than 1%?
Do you know that, at least?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah, for
practical uses, this gets you,
I think to 1% of 1% of 1%.
So usually, put a Bloom filter
before a really expensive
check, and the Bloom
filter gets rid of most
of the false positives.
And then you have
a few more where
you do the more expensive check.
Okay, does this make sense?
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you more optimal
if you repeated this Bloom
filter independently
of the other one,
with more hash functions
in that memory structure?
PROFESSOR: I think doubling
the memory size is better.
So two filters is the
same as having two n bits.
I think doubling gives you
better results, always.
OK, so general stuff.
We're going to have a lot
of conceptual questions,
so please make sure, again,
make sure that for everything
that we did, go
through the problem.
Understand the problem, know
that there is a solution.
Know the running
time, maybe know
how to implement the solution.
Don't worry so much
about the proof.
We're going to have
some problems where
you have to come up with
new things on your own,
so get a good night's
sleep before the exam.
Really, if you have
five hours left,
then you have to choose
between sleeping five hours
or reading notes
for five hours--
AUDIENCE: Drink caffeine.
PROFESSOR: It's
not going to help,
so caffeine actually
helps you stay up,
but it decreases
your performance.
And so if you're on caffeine,
you're not going to think.
You can regurgitate stuff,
but you can't think.
So caffeinating yourself is a--
AUDIENCE: I thought it was like
it gives you concentration.
PROFESSOR: So there's an optimum
amount of sleep and caffeine
combination.
If you don't sleep and
caffeinate yourself,
I guarantee that
you will not solve
any of the problems that
require new algorithms.
AUDIENCE: Caffeine just squirts
adrenaline in your brain.
It doesn't do anything else.
PROFESSOR: So the thing is the
memory is going to be better.
If all you're doing
is memorization stuff,
then it's going to be better.
So you're going to do well on
the pattern matching stuff.
But when your
brain is panicking,
you're not going to come up
with new solutions, right?
Usually, you have a
problem, a hard problem.
You're thinking about it,
and then at some point
when you're relaxed, like
when you're in the shower
or when you wake up you're
like, crap, I found a solution.
So the brain finds
solutions when it's relaxed,
not when it's like, holy
shit, holy shit, holy shit.
And adrenaline gets
it in that mood.
That's what it does.
And that's what caffeine
does in the end.
So a little bit of caffeine
might help you get up
and get you running,
but don't caffeinate
yourself to not sleep
the entire night.
That's probably going to make
you bomb the hard questions.
Good luck on Friday.
Eat candy.